we you mentioned earlier some planning
and tracking software I'm wondering in
terms of screenwriting programs can it
really teach someone to be a better
writer no you know truly writing is
inspiration writing is a craft if you
get a hammer it's not going to teach you
how to be a better carpenter and may
make the creation of carpentry easier so
I'm going to teach you how to be a
better writer you know it is a craft
it's a craft that has to be practiced
sure they're tools like dramatical to
help you etcetera etcetera and save the
cat and all of those but you know I've
seen writers take on save the cat and
not get screenwriting to save their
lives it's not paint-by-numbers and you
know if you're color blind painting my
numbers is really not going to work for
you and that's pretty much the equation
so I think that all of those things have
their uses and I think that they can be
very important guides for the mechanics
of your work but you the writer are
going to have to master the craft I'm a
big believer in Malcolm Gladwell's
10,000 hours you shouldn't be shy of
getting those you know for most writers
the first script is not going to be the
script the second script is not going to
be the script you're going to have to
really get better at your craft and
there's no short cutting that even if
you filled out the you know 40 beats of
save the cats perfectly that does not
mean a perfect script ever right Sigma
home Gladwell's the outlier we mean in
terms of environment fostering genius or
genius already being in someone but
environment either hindering it or
getting it out there have you seen that
we're certainly listen there has to be a
kernel of genius there you can be a
technically proficient writer but if
you're not able to invest some soul in
your work if you're not able to really
get a feel the way that it sings then it
will always feel mechanical you know I
had a girlfriend growing up who really
really wanted to be a great pianist she
never felt it so her playing was
entirely proficient but entirely cold
and the same thing happens with
screenplays there has to be some whether
we want to call a genius or anything
else talent something innate that you're
able to invest in the work it makes it
uniquely your own or else it just
becomes a perfectly technically executed
screenplay but not a great screenplay
and I do believe that that's the
difference between good and great it's
that extra thing and certainly
environment can nurture or destroy it
but I've seen I can tell you sadly that
I've seen writers come to screenwriting
and really really really want to get it
but they don't and you tried every
dinner allows I was speaking recently to
a friend who's a UCLA instructor who
said you know I always I always believe
that anybody can be taught how to write
and then once a while somebody walks in
my class and reminds me that now that's
just not the case there are some things
that either you understand them innately
or you don't I think most people that
come to this come with some innate
understanding of screenwriting with the
flow of screenwriting with the general
structure of the general rhythm of
screenwriting but I think you certainly
want an environment to nurture it to
promote it and to help you rise to your
very best